and across Nova Scotia people are being
asked to hunker down with that winter
storm continuing to Pound The
Province up to 80 cmers of snow has
fallen in some places this weekend in
Cape Breton they've declared a local
state of emergency after receiving news
the province is not willing to declare
one across Nova Scotia this local state
of emergency will last for 7 days now
that sounds like a long time what if we
get cleared up before them well then we
can take it back we can re acted we can
we can make sure that things are opened
up but for the time being this is what
council felt is the best thing to do to
keep people safe in Halifax residents
are being urged to avoid non-essential
travel transit services cautiously
resumed around noon today after they
were halted this morning airport
services were also limited with many
flights canceled or delayed the
overnight winter parking ban will
continue to be enforced in both Zone 1
Central and Zone 2 non-c Central
tomorrow from 1: to 6:00 a.m. also
schools will remain closed tomorrow to
allow for snow clearing
efforts